[Music]
on this Thursday night the past and who
we've honored colliding with the present
from street names to statues the push to
erase names with racist ties why would
you want to identify with someone who
opposes the abolition of slavery the
debate gaining momentum
the art of racial justice it's really
beautiful to see one Ali's
transformation and tribute to black
lives playing the blame game they
blocked help liberals shamefully saying
no the bickering over disability
benefits plus a textbook case of stress
why international students are in limbo
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the growing pressure to
recognize systemic racism in Canada and
take action to eliminate it especially
in policing yesterday the Commissioner
of the RCMP said while she believes
there's unconscious bias she can't say
for sure if there's systemic racism in
the RCMP and she said she struggles with
the definition of it today Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau made it clear
what he thinks systemic racism is an
issue right across the country in all
our institutions including in all our
police forces including in the RCMP
that's what systemic racism is so as
much as we admire and support the RCMP
we know we need to do better and it's
not just the individual examples we've
seen it's the issues faced by Canadians
of diverse backgrounds over years
decades and generations Trudeau says he
does still have confidence in the RCMP
commissioner and beyond police reform
there are calls to rethink who we choose
to honor from our past in Vancouver this
morning the statue of British explorer
Captain George Vancouver was found
covered in paint similar scenes are
playing out in cities around the world
monuments to men who were once honoured
now viewed by a new generation as
symbols of racism and colonialism relics
of the past not standing the test of
time in some cases City officials are
taking them down themselves because of
the public pressure here in Canada a
push is underway to take a harder look
at historical names attached to our
schools and our streets one is Henry
Dundas he was a big political figure
from Scotland in the 19th century
tonight Eric Sorensen looks at the
campaign to wipe his name from signs all
over Ontario including in Canada's
biggest city as protesters marched
through Toronto's iconic Yonge Dundas
Square last week few probably realized
that Dundas Street
is a name now being scrutinized over
cannabis history on race do you know
where the name Dundas Street comes from
actually no I'm not sure that person was
Henry Dundas Britain's Lord of the
Admiralty more than 200 years ago and
when Toronto was being designed a major
street was named for him but Henry
Dundas also blocked Britain's abolition
of slavery for 15 years and that say
critics is not a legacy Toronto should
embrace by having the name Dundas
emblazoned on street corners all over
the city
why would you want to identify with
someone who opposed the abolition of
slavery why would that be meaningful
Dundas is not just a major street name
in Toronto as you go west it just keeps
going
so other communities are also
confronting the history of the name
Dundas Dundas Street carries on from
Toronto through Mississauga and several
more communities in southern Ontario all
the way to London in Hamilton a
community called Dundas still exists in
Woodstock Dundas was a Main Street a
century ago and it still is today and in
London Ontario a major artery right
through downtown and its history there
is also now being questioned right now
we're having a conversation about
something that is very important not
only to a group of racialized community
members but as far as the nation is
concerned I think this is where we're
going to start to get some healing and
understanding Canada is not alone
examining Henry Dundas some in Scotland
want an enormous statue of the man taken
down across Canada many historic figures
and symbols are now being viewed through
the lens of racism even examining our
history criticizing it their slavery
existed in Canada existed in New France
we can't deny it we can't escape from it
in Toronto
thousands of petition to rename Dundas
Street no easy feat renaming a major
street or public space does create many
practical challenges but we should have
a process that it can examine what are
very important and relevant historical
questions in southern Ontario millions
are familiar with the name Dundas is it
time to expunge or at least diminish its
prominence in our myth
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto that
anger is about passed in Justices but
it's fueled by what's still happening
today another video has been released in
the United States showing the arrest of
a black man its police body cam footage
from Oklahoma City and a warning it is
disturbing to watch police say 42 year
old Derek Scott was confronted after
they received reports a man was
brandishing a gun well pinned to the
ground Scott says multiple times I can't
breathe one officer says I don't care
one had her knee between his shoulder
blades and others straddled his back for
about 13 minutes he died shortly after
his arrest the video was released by
police after Scott's family and a local
black lives matter group demanded more
details the officers have been cleared
of any wrongdoing black activists are
demanding it stopped demanding that
black boys should not have to grow up
wondering if they might be next as
Jackson prosecco reports that's going to
take leadership and a willingness to
change and there are no signs of that
coming from the White House the
[Applause]
reckoning has come to every corner of
America a statue of Christopher Columbus
toppled in Minneapolis Confederate
monuments ripped down in Virginia the
Confederate flag banned from all NASCAR
events and in Washington a push to take
down monuments inside the Capitol and to
rename US military bases named for
Confederate generals through this
national upheaval President Donald Trump
remained steadfastly on the opposite
side bowing to not even consider
renaming bases in the past objecting to
the removal of monuments and then you
had the president make a case as to why
a base should be named for them he seems
to be the only person left who doesn't
get it
Trump has largely projected silence even
as those around him break theirs it was
a mistake that I've learned from the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
issued a public apology for a pier
alongside the president after protesters
were forcibly cleared from outside the
White House to make way for a photo-op
last week I should not have been there
my presence in that moment and in that
environment created a perception of the
military involved in domestic politics
meanwhile Trump himself has failed to
address the issues of race that sparked
the protests his first scheduled
campaign event in months is mired in
racial overtones Trump will speak to
supporters in Tulsa Oklahoma site of one
of the worst race massacres in US
history on the day known as Juneteenth
which commemorates the end of slavery
it's a slap in the face I think it's a
total insult to the black community and
to the city of Tulsa we're going to
choose Juneteenth to come in campaign
that's unlikely to slow down a nation on
the march toward change Jackson cross go
Global News Washington
lots of Americans are calling for
political change in November's
presidential election is fast
approaching Donald Trump's Democratic
rival Jill Biden says he's worried Trump
might refuse to relinquish power if he
loses in an interview on The Daily Show
host Trevor Noah asked Biden what his
plan is to ensure everyone has the
opportunity to cast a ballot without
waiting in lines that are six hours long
the way people did in Georgia on Tuesday
my greatest concern my single greatest
concern this president's going to try to
steal this election this is a guy who
said that all mail-in ballots are
fraudulent directly voting by mail while
he sits behind the desk in Oval Office
and writes his mail-in ballot to vote in
the primary the voting problems in
Georgia's primary were terrible from
extremely long waits to malfunctioning
voting machines some blame the state
government for inadequate training
others say it was about voter
suppression tactics in a state with a
history of racist election practices
local and state officials are
investigating why it went so wrong
the US has marked another grim Kovan 19
milestone more than 2 million cases have
now been diagnosed in that country and
in countries like Canada where infection
rates
relatively low the World Health
Organization is urging officials to
remain on high alert
the biggest threat now it says is
complacency almost 75 percent of recent
cases come from just 10 countries mostly
in the Americas and South Asia in Africa
the pandemic is accelerating more than
200,000 cases have been confirmed there
and more than 5,600 deaths and more than
10,000 new infections were reported in
India today bringing the total in that
country to more than two hundred and
ninety seven thousand here in Canada
Ontario recorded two hundred and three
new cases of kovat 19 today that's the
lowest number in nearly 11 weeks both
Premier Doug Ford and his health
minister who themselves were tested
yesterday say the results are negative
and there's some good news for long-term
care residents - beginning June 18th in
Ontario visits will be allowed at the
facilities that don't have covin 19
outbreaks there will be strict rules
they must take place outside visitors
must remain physically distant and must
have tested negative for the virus in
the past two weeks
many Canadians struggling to pay the
bills are relying on federal emergency
benefits now the Canada Revenue Agency
says 190,000 Canadians who received cerb
payments they weren't entitled to have
repaid them but the Liberal government
has failed to secure enough political
support to fast-track emergency
legislation related to other benefits
our chief political correspondent David
akin joins me to explain what's at stake
David well Donna the legislation is
known as bill c-17 and it proposes to do
quite a few things first it would
provide for sanctions against anyone
found to have fraudulently received any
serb payment pay back twice what was
illegally obtained and pay a fine of up
to five thousand dollars or face up to
six months in jail but c-17 does more
than just that it also provides a
one-time $600 payment to anyone
receiving the disability tax credit it
would also expand the wage subsidy
program to include more seasonal workers
but c-17 is stalled because all three
opposition parties refused unanimous
consent needed
to pass legislation in a single day
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau mostly
blame the Conservatives so because they
didn't get their way two weeks ago they
continued to complain and play politics
and they blocked help the Canadians with
disabilities conservatives rejected the
accusation mr. chair the mistake
yesterday was liberals shamefully saying
no to allow Parliament to deal with that
legislation and then disgustingly today
trying to play petty politics on the
backs of people with disabilities that's
shameful mr. chair the bloc québécois
wants the Trudeau government to table a
fiscal update while the NDP says
limiting help only to those who file the
tax return and claim the disability tax
credit is wrong the problem with the
Liberal plan is it completely misses 60%
of Canadians who live with the
disability advocates for those with
disabilities have one message for Ottawa
sorted out the government really needs
to assess where their values are at and
the opposition needs to take a look at
their response Canadians with
disabilities make up 22% of the
population and we are definitely voters
in the meantime the Prime Minister said
his government would try to find some
other way to get this one-time $600
payment out the door to those who filed
for a disability tax credit details
TBD Donna all right David akin in Ottawa
thank you the doctor being blamed for a
kovat 19 outbreak in new brunswick says
he's not responsible and wants a public
apology from the premier dr. Jean Robert
Angola says he's faced threats and
attacks since the province announced an
outbreak in campbellton last month it
was linked to a doctor who came back
from a trip to Quebec and did not self
isolate premier Blaine Higgs never
publicly named Angola but the doctors
lawyers said today he was outed online
Angola did travel to Quebec in May his
lawyers says a private investigator
found evidence the doctor contracted the
virus in New Brunswick
there's no way to point the finger
scientifically that doctor no Cola is
the cause of disease in your Brunswick
certainly based on the contact tracing
that our investigator has done
and based on the evidence there at the
same time there's I don't think there's
any way to point the finger at anybody
because of the way this disease spreads
Angola is seeking an apology but his
lawyer says he's not ruling out further
legal action today premier Blaine Higgs
stood by his statement saying the facts
are clear in this case and that he never
identified the doctor a new degree of
anxiety for international students
coming up why their future is so
uncertain
during this pandemic
everyone is trying to make plans for the
future in the midst of the pandemic
including university students new data
from Ontario shows students are
accepting university admissions offers
at almost the same rate as before the
pandemic there are sharp contrasts among
schools but overall there's almost no
difference between this year and last
though much of the teaching will likely
be done virtually enrollment numbers
especially from international students
is weighing heavily on schools across
the country right now
many post-secondary institutions rely on
international students for funding and
as Michael Couture explains there's
concerns some won't be able to return to
class in the fall campuses across the
country remain quiet as many
post-secondary institutions that move
classes online for the foreseeable
future but that reduction in in-person
learning won't mean the reduction in
tuition and that's significant for
international students who often pay
double compared to Canadian students at
most post-secondary institutions there
should be an appropriate response in
terms of tuition how much we're paying
since we are we are all affected by this
he launched a petition to convince his
school to lower tuition for
international students Dalhousie
University recently announced it's
raising tuition for all students by 3
percent saying it will help maintain the
high quality of academic programming the
group that advocates for Canadian
universities said in a statement many
universities are administering emergency
bursaries and extending access to
university residences for international
students adding universities Canada is
working with the federal government to
help international students study in
this country during the pandemic all our
efforts and investments might be in a
risky a tuition is a concern for a
Duluth Simsek but a more pressing issue
is whether or not school delays caused
by the pandemic will prevent her from
finishing her degree before her student
visa expires the program in this one
year
it might be very tough to find a job and
get Kennedy in experience and yet PR
studies it's why the migrant workers
Alliance for change is calling on the
government to give all international
students permanent residency status
since many aren't eligible for emergency
government aid there's an economic
downturn making it difficult for
students to find employment even
survival jobs and employment that would
give them access to permanent residency
in a statement a spokesperson for the
Immigration Minister responded
international students currently in
Canada who had their classes moved
online as part of efforts to flatten the
curve of kovat 19 will not affect their
eligibility for the post graduation work
permit program adding international
students or other temporary residents
can renew or extend their visas online a
helpful step perhaps but still not the
long-term certainty those students are
looking for my click Reuter global news
Ottawa cash-strapped creativity still
ahead the airline selling art in
turbulent times
Air Canada's CEO is calling for a
loosening of travel restrictions so more
people can fly Callan Rovin sq calls the
government's rules disproportionate he
wants the ability to do what he called
some reasonable amounts of business air
canada has laid off 20,000 employees
most international flights have been
canceled and the US Canada border has
been shut down to non-essential travel
since March 21st the restrictions are
expected to be in place until at least
late July
that's when Air Transat hopes to resume
its flights after a nearly four month
hiatus starting July 23rd the airline
plans to offer 23 flights to places in
Canada the US Europe and the Caribbean
new safety procedures will be in place
Air Transat reports it lost 179 million
dollars between February and May stray
some much-needed cash and protect
thousands of jobs British Airways is
auctioning off some art at least ten
famous works that hang in the airline's
lounges and headquarters are earmarked
for sale
some have been valued by Sotheby's
auction house at over 1 million dollars
this iconic alley in downtown Toronto
has received a black lives matter
makeover I'm micro Lai I'll explain more
coming up on global national
[Music]
you are watching global national art is
inspired by life an artist in Toronto
are using their skills to express their
views on current events and show
solidarity with the black lives matter
movement micro lay takes us to graffiti
alley
chucked in behind all the glass towers
and high fashion shops lies one of
Toronto's unlikeliest attractions
it's called graffiti alley street art
that's become a magnet for Instagram
posts and which recently got a more
socially aware makeover I don't really
see a lot of political work in our city
the first mural painted really sets the
tone for the rest of the alley
all power to the people was a slogan for
the Black Panther Party which was a
movement created in the 1960s initially
to monitor police violence in the black
community street art has long been
viewed as an expression of the now and
there's no name more relevant to that
idea than George Floyd the Minneapolis
man who died while being restrained by
police he's prominently displayed here
along with his last words I can't
breathe inside the oh of the lettering
you see the names listed of five people
in 2020 who passed away under similar
circumstances so Brianna Taylor Ahmad
ivory Douglas C Lewis David Mackey and
Regis Kochanski Paquette in a way art is
his voice what he paints here will speak
to thousands through social media people
he otherwise would never meet there is
historic precedence thousands of murals
were used as a way to stay connected in
Northern Ireland during the Troubles and
most recently Mexican artists Enrique
Chiu enlisted 3800 volunteers to paint
uplifting messages along the Mexican
side of the border with the u.s. it's
art activism and a message you have to
paint over to a race I think I'm not
alone as a as a white guy a white person
feeling the pain of society you know
feeling agony watching what's happening
and thinking and reading about what you
know how Canada is really not a whole
lot better for people of color when it
comes to police brutality graffiti won't
solve society's ills but it tells a
story and hopefully reaches people who
otherwise wouldn't listen
microlight Global News Toronto and that
is global national for this Thursday I'm
donor Friesen tonight share Canada is
the Shuswap river in Enderby DC we'd
love to see your Canada please email it
to viewers at global national comm
thanks for watching Robin Gill will be
here tomorrow and I will see you on
Sunday for the new reality take care of
yourselves
bye bye
[Music]